HAMAS.IESTA DTHFY THE RENSOURCEG
ADLADOREAC U
KI AISS?.DETHHCER,
EAN, ] ND ANDT
THL NGSOMOR TH
OTT CORT YB TE EVT.>>
LEN  ONEO MYE E F TOENGAODAKOFAR
SO'SOTD OL PHA'SNLUD S SFAIR>>I
WE.ITYOEAHAUGGPSCLREU.RYG IOADV
SUSLLPEAFUHEINREVEERSTNALLUTONZE
OOTU  NME RSETAL
ENE.LEMSO,RE D C AALETTIINOURE
INT M  HKNEEEA
TI
S,F BEULOUTH
E INGALAES OS.ATUPNDYPE TO
T TERESEN
F, 'SY BNIFUAV AEEINSE OASRIEAR
THMIE NTYPYAS A
Y STHOMT
TEIO UTO
KICCCAIN
BLNCK -TWA FAN
DINIO ART
MOOM
-RSO
TEDI
SAECAL.NT
TLPOM FARIG ITNCIZE ANTOORNG
TE OS.>>N REER
BAOR
ATABONOTD  PIRETN
RRE SSLI TLOIBPERM DASRAUR F
IT REACOMANAN WS IN[I MCK
E >>ESNGSUCE
PRCI.
YPIBZESIEDOEOND .SEIT N
ILALIVLI
NGE IAY ,  TFRRE T
TH M
. UISY  DG Y,
. N ASOISHAEER THEASOOM, VEHASOE
ASEPP NINIBEEOMLL SCU S
ON CE
T
H.NE
S.AN FERITEY MEDHO M A
TH
N E TO
E
D
20 CW  GONI IAW Y  D
TEWH>> AUSY E
ARINF , ?
EFO GCE
GRUT WHA, YSAM] TH $THTANHRWI DA
MRMO  AY IN
UAUSORARE THSO
AVYOOWD ASLLUNG.WENCGRSEARTYPT
S OMAWETSS D 19E 41 TIS
D EETH.LDTOU T.OW
ATPSF  MSAT BIGF  HBLTO23
HE W Y T
T.HE
ICRANTO H
FINDE
RRSECUNGORNTG CALA
CISRECYMEREANMAUN
OR